Erinome: This is State of Play, Episode 65. I'm Erinome, and today we're spending about forty minutes on a single launch that landed in the inbox this week, because it deserves the depth. Anthropic has released Claude Science, described as an AI workbench for scientists, and it's now generally available. On the surface that reads like another product announcement in a crowded field. Underneath it, there are four threads worth pulling apart carefully: the workbench itself and what it actually does, an agent design pattern hiding inside it that has wider application, the question of running these tools locally when you're handling identifiable data, and the way it abstracts compute across high performance clusters and cloud services like Modal. We'll take each in turn, and at the end we'll map how they interlock, because they interlock in a way that matters if you build clinical or research tooling.
Erinome: Let me set the frame before others come in. When a general-purpose model vendor ships a domain workbench, the interesting question is never "can it write Python for a scientist." Of course it can. The interesting question is what scaffolding they've wrapped around the model to make it trustworthy inside a workflow where wrong answers have consequences. That's where we'll spend our time. Rasalgethi, you've had a look at what's actually in the box. Start us off on the mechanics.
Rasalgethi: I'm Rasalgethi. Happy to. So strip away the marketing and Claude Science is three things stitched together. First, it's an interface where a scientist states a goal in plain language, something like "compare the differential expression between these two cohorts and flag anything significant after multiple testing correction." Second, it's an execution layer that turns that goal into actual runnable code, executes it against your data, and returns not just an answer but the code that produced the answer, the plots, and a log of what it did. Third, and this is the part people skip past, it has a review step built into the loop. The model that writes the analysis is not the same voice that signs off on it.
Rasalgethi: Why does that third piece matter so much? Because the single biggest failure mode of a language model doing data analysis is confident wrongness. It'll run a t-test on data that violates the assumptions of a t-test, report a p-value to three decimal places, and never mention that the distribution is bimodal and the whole test is meaningless. A scientist reading a clean output has no reason to suspect anything. So the value isn't in generating the analysis. Generating analysis is cheap now. The value is in catching the analysis that's plausible but wrong. That's what the workbench is trying to systematise.
Erinome: And that catch mechanism is the thread I want to open up next, because it's not unique to science. Kore, you looked at this as a knowledge-management and reproducibility question. What did you see?
Kore: I'm Kore. What struck me is that the workbench treats the analysis as a document, not as an ephemeral chat. When you ask a normal chat assistant to do statistics, the reasoning evaporates the moment you close the window. The output lives in your head or in a screenshot. Claude Science is built so that every analysis produces a durable artefact: the natural-language goal, the generated code, the environment it ran in, the result, and the review notes. That bundle is the record. You can hand it to a collaborator, you can re-run it, you can audit it six months later when a reviewer asks how you got a number.
Kore: This is a bigger deal than it sounds, because reproducibility in science is broken precisely at the last mile. People have their data, they have their statistical software, and the missing piece is the faithful record of what button they clicked, what parameter they set, what version of the library they used. Most retractions and most failures to replicate trace back to that gap, not to fraud and not to bad data. If a tool makes the record automatic and complete, that's a genuine contribution regardless of how clever the model is. I'd go further: the record is arguably the product. The analysis is the byproduct.
Erinome: That's a strong claim and I want to hold it up against the sceptical view, because there's a version of this that sounds good and works badly. Achernar, push on it.
Achernar: I'm Achernar. I'll push. The durable-record framing is attractive, but a record is only as trustworthy as the thing generating it, and here's where I get careful. If the model writes the code, runs the code, and also writes the review notes, then the record is internally consistent but not independently validated. It's a closed loop. The reviewer voice and the author voice come from the same underlying weights. They share the same blind spots. If the model doesn't understand that your data are zero-inflated count data, it won't understand that in the author role and it won't understand it in the reviewer role either. So you get a beautifully documented, fully reproducible, confidently wrong analysis. Reproducing a mistake faithfully is not the same as catching it.
Achernar: The evidence on this is uncomfortable. When you have one model critique another model's output, you do get improvement, but the improvement is bounded by what the models collectively know. The failures that survive are the correlated ones, the errors both instances make. And those are exactly the errors that matter most, because they're systematic, not random. So my position is: the review loop is real value on the margin, it catches the careless mistakes, the off-by-one, the wrong column, the forgotten correction. It does not substitute for a human who actually understands the domain. Anyone who treats the sign-off as a sign-off is going to get burned.
Erinome: Let me stay on this, because you and Rasalgethi are describing the same feature and reaching different conclusions. Rasalgethi, respond to the correlated-errors point directly.
Rasalgethi: It's a fair hit and I won't pretend it isn't. The correlated-error problem is real. But I'd separate two things. There's the error the model can't see because it doesn't have the knowledge, and there's the error the model can see if it's prompted into the right stance. A lot of statistical mistakes are in the second category. The model knows that a t-test assumes roughly normal distributions. It knows that count data usually wants a different family. When it's rushing to answer, in author mode, it skips the assumption check. When you explicitly cast it into a critic role and ask "what assumptions does this analysis make, and are they satisfied by this data," it will frequently catch its own shortcut. Not because it learned anything new, but because the framing surfaced knowledge it already had.
Rasalgethi: So the actor-critic split isn't buying you knowledge you didn't have. It's buying you attention you didn't spend. And that's genuinely useful, because most of the time the model isn't wrong from ignorance, it's wrong from haste. Achernar is right that it won't save you from the deep unknown. I'd just say the shallow-but-common errors are the bulk of what goes wrong in day-to-day analysis, and this catches a real slice of those.
Achernar: I'll accept that distinction. Attention versus knowledge is the right cut. My caution stands for the knowledge-gap errors, but I agree the attention errors are worth catching and they're common.
Erinome: Good. That actor-critic pattern is the second thread and it's the one with the widest application beyond this product, so let's stay on it a moment longer and generalise. Charon, you think about this as a design pattern for building tools, not just as a feature of one workbench. Lay out the pattern and where it transfers.
Charon: I'm Charon. So the pattern, stated cleanly, is this. You have one agent whose job is to produce work: write the code, draft the letter, propose the plan. You have a second agent, running separately, whose only job is to find fault with that work against an explicit checklist. The critic doesn't rewrite. It flags. Then either the author revises in response, or a human adjudicates the flags. The key discipline is that the critic has a different prompt, a different stance, and ideally a narrower, sharper mandate than the author. The author is optimising for a good answer. The critic is optimising for finding the flaw. Those are different objectives and you get better results when you don't ask one call to do both.
Charon: Where does this transfer? Almost anywhere you have a generation step whose failure is expensive. Think about a clinical summarisation tool that reads a discharge and drafts a letter to a GP. The author drafts. The critic checks: does every medication in the letter appear in the source, is any dose changed, is any allergy dropped, does the letter claim a result that isn't in the record. That critic is not writing prose. It's running a factual-consistency audit. That's a bounded, checkable task, and a model is much better at "does this claim appear in this source" than it is at "write me a perfect letter from scratch." So you split the hard open-ended job from the narrow checking job, and you get a system that's more reliable than either half alone.
Charon: The mistake people make is building the critic as a vibe check, "is this good, yes or no." That's useless. The critic needs an explicit itemised checklist to test against, and every flag it raises should point at a specific claim and a specific reason. If the critic can't cite the offending line, the flag is noise. Build the checklist first, then build the critic around it.
Erinome: That's the design principle I most want listeners to take away, so let me restate it plainly. If you're building any tool where a language model produces something that a human will act on, add a second model call whose entire job is to check the first one against a written checklist, and require it to cite the specific line for every objection. That's a concrete implementation. Step one, write the checklist of failure modes that matter in your domain. Step two, run generation. Step three, run the critic against the checklist, forcing line-level citations. Step four, present the human with the draft plus the flagged lines, not a yes-no verdict. Kore, does the durable-record piece slot into this?
Kore: It does, and this is where the two threads start to knit. The critic's flags become part of the record. So you don't just store "here's the analysis." You store "here's the analysis, here are the seven things the critic checked, here are the two it flagged, here's how the author resolved them." Now the record isn't just reproducible, it's legible. A reviewer six months later can see not only what was done but what was questioned and answered. That's a much stronger provenance trail than a bare output. And it maps directly onto how careful humans already work: the good analyst keeps a lab notebook of what they worried about and how they checked it. The workbench is automating the notebook, not just the sums.
Erinome: Let's move to the third thread, because it's the one that decides whether any of this is usable in Jacob's actual context. Identifiable data. Local execution. Iapetus, you've been sitting with the governance question. Where does the data go, and why is that the whole ballgame for clinical work?
Iapetus: I'm Iapetus. It is the whole ballgame, and I want to be precise rather than alarmist. When you run an analysis with a hosted AI workbench, there are two very different things that can happen to your data, and the marketing often blurs them. One: your data are sent to a remote server, the model reads them directly, and they sit in that vendor's environment during processing. Two: the model never sees the raw data at all. Instead the model writes code, the code runs where your data live, and only the code and the results, the plots, the summary statistics, travel. Those are radically different risk profiles, and Claude Science is built around the second one, which is the right architecture.
Iapetus: Here's why that distinction is load-bearing for identifiable health data. If you're working with a cohort that includes names, dates of birth, addresses, or any combination that re-identifies a person, then sending those rows to a third-party server is a governance event. It engages privacy legislation, ethics approvals, data custodianship agreements, often data sovereignty requirements about where information physically resides. For a lot of Australian health data, moving identifiable records offshore isn't a preference question, it's a hard stop written into the approval you got to hold the data in the first place. So a workbench that ships your raw rows to a remote model is simply unusable for that work, no matter how good it is.
Iapetus: But a workbench where the model writes code that executes locally, against data that never leaves your machine or your institution's controlled environment, is a completely different proposition. The model sees the schema, maybe some synthetic or aggregate previews, and the instructions. It writes the analysis. The analysis runs where the data are. Only de-identified results come back. That architecture can sit inside your governance envelope, because the identifiable data never crossed a boundary. The launch materials lean on exactly this: keeping execution and sensitive data local while using the hosted model only for reasoning and code generation.
Erinome: Achernar, the sceptic's version of this. Is "the code runs locally" actually enough, or is that a comforting story with holes in it?
Achernar: It's better than the alternative and it still has holes, and both those things are true. The good part: if execution is genuinely local and only aggregate results return, you've closed the biggest leak. The holes are in the word "genuinely" and in what counts as an aggregate. Two specific worries. First, prompt leakage. Even if the raw rows stay home, the instructions you send to the model can inadvertently carry identifiers. If you write "analyse the readmission pattern for patient cohort from this specific small rural clinic in this specific month," you may have just described a re-identifiable group in your prompt, and that prompt went to the server. The data stayed home; the description that pinpoints the people did not.
Achernar: Second worry: small-cell disclosure in the results. You told me only aggregates come back. But an aggregate over a tiny group is not safe. "Mean age of the three patients with this rare condition in this town" is effectively identifying. So the local-execution architecture protects the raw table but does nothing about the two ends, the prompt going out and the summary coming back. A responsible deployment has to police both. My rule would be: treat the prompt as if it's leaving the building, because it is, and treat every returned aggregate as requiring the same small-cell suppression you'd apply before publishing anything. Local execution is necessary. It is not sufficient.
Iapetus: I agree with all of that, and it strengthens rather than undermines the case. The architecture gives you the container. You still have to fill it responsibly. The concrete implementation for someone in Jacob's position would be a three-layer discipline. Layer one, the data stay local, enforced by running execution on infrastructure you control. Layer two, a prompt hygiene rule: no free-text identifiers in the goal you send, describe cohorts by de-identified criteria only, never by name-plus-place-plus-time. Layer three, an output gate: every result that returns gets small-cell suppression, any group under a threshold like five or ten gets masked, before it's shown or stored. Get those three layers right and the workbench becomes usable for exactly the kind of identifiable clinical data that most hosted tools lock you out of.
Erinome: That three-layer discipline is worth writing down and putting on the wall next to whoever builds this. Data local, prompt clean, output suppressed. Let's take the fourth thread now, because it connects to something Jacob already cares about, which is not being locked into one place to run compute. Charon, the workbench abstracts over different execution backends, high performance clusters and cloud services like Modal. Walk us through what that abstraction buys and what it costs.
Charon: Right. So the workbench doesn't just say "here's your code, run it yourself." It knows how to dispatch that code to different execution environments. If you have access to an institutional high performance computing cluster, the kind of shared research supercomputer a university runs, it can target that. If you'd rather burst to a cloud service, and Modal is the named example, a platform that lets you spin up compute on demand and pay for what you use, it can target that instead. The scientist writes the analysis once, at the level of intent, and the workbench handles the plumbing of getting it onto whichever backend you point it at.
Charon: What that buys you is real. Most scientists lose enormous time on the gap between "I know what analysis I want" and "I have it running on hardware that can actually do it." Cluster job schedulers are arcane. Environment setup is fragile. Getting your libraries and your data and your job script to agree with each other on a shared cluster is a genuine skill that has nothing to do with your science. If the workbench absorbs that friction, a scientist who is not a systems administrator gets to run heavy compute without becoming one. That's the same democratisation move as the analysis generation, applied one layer down, to the infrastructure.
Charon: Now this ties straight back to Iapetus's governance point, and this is the connection I most want to make. The compute abstraction is the same lever as the data-locality control. Because "where does this run" and "where does my data live" are the same question. If the workbench lets you point execution at your controlled cluster, then your data stay in your controlled environment and the model never touches them. If it can only run on the vendor's own compute, you're back to shipping data out. So the ability to abstract over backends is not just a convenience feature. It's the mechanism by which you keep identifiable data inside your governance boundary. The two threads are one thread.
Erinome: Say more on the cost side, though. Abstraction always hides something. What's the tax?
Charon: The tax is that abstraction over backends means you don't fully control any of them. When the analysis runs cleanly, wonderful, you never think about it. When it fails, you're now debugging through a layer that's translating your intent into someone else's job scheduler, and the error message you get back may be three translations removed from what actually went wrong. There's also a cost model to watch. Bursting to on-demand cloud compute is fast and frictionless right up until you run a poorly-bounded job that spins up a lot of expensive hardware and bills accordingly. The abstraction that makes it easy to run heavy compute also makes it easy to accidentally run expensive compute. And there's a subtler lock-in risk: if all your analyses are written to the workbench's abstraction rather than to portable, plain code, then leaving the workbench later means rewriting your pipeline. Convenience now, dependency later. My advice is to insist the workbench emits portable code you could run without it. If it does, the abstraction is a genuine gift. If it doesn't, it's a leash with good ergonomics.
Erinome: Let me bring the ethics voice in on that lock-in point, because it's not only a technical concern. Achernar, is there a sovereignty argument here beyond the practical one?
Achernar: There is, and it's the same argument we keep coming back to in different clothes. Sovereignty over your tools means you can leave. If a research group builds its whole analytical practice on top of a workbench, and the workbench emits its own proprietary flavour of pipeline rather than plain, portable code, then the group has traded independence for convenience without necessarily deciding to. That's the trade that should be made consciously, not by default. For a public-good or clinical context especially, where you may need to hand your methods to a regulator, a coroner, an ethics committee, or a collaborating institution that doesn't use the same tool, portability isn't a nice-to-have. It's part of accountability. Your methods have to be inspectable by people who don't have your vendor login. So I'd put "emits portable code" not just on Charon's engineering wishlist but on the ethics checklist. The record has to survive the tool.
Erinome: That's a clean bridge back to Kore's durable-record thread, and it's a good moment to do the synergy pass, because these four threads don't sit side by side, they compound. Let me map how, and then I'll ask each of you to sharpen one edge of it.
Erinome: Here's the interlock. Thread one, the actor-critic review pattern, gives you generation you can trust more, because a second stance checks the first against a checklist. Thread two, the durable legible record, captures not just the analysis but the checking, so provenance is complete. Thread three, local execution with prompt hygiene and output suppression, keeps identifiable data inside your governance boundary so the whole thing is usable on real clinical data instead of toy data. Thread four, compute abstraction over your own cluster, is the mechanism that makes thread three physically true, because running on infrastructure you control is what keeps the data home. Put them together and you get something specific: a system where a non-specialist can run governed analysis on sensitive data, with a built-in second-opinion check, that produces a portable, auditable record a regulator could read. No single thread gets you there. Remove any one and the whole thing degrades. Remove local execution, you can't touch real data. Remove the critic, you can't trust the output. Remove portability, you can't defend the method. Remove the record, you can't reproduce any of it.
Erinome: Now the counterexample I want to name so nobody oversells this. The four together also stack four failure modes. Charon, name the compound risk.
Charon: The compound risk is a fully automated, beautifully documented, locally-run, portable-code analysis that is confidently wrong, and now carries all the trappings of rigour. The record makes it look audited. The critic gave it a tick. The local execution made it feel governed. The portable code made it feel defensible. And it's still wrong, in the deep-knowledge way Achernar warned about, the correlated error both models share. The danger of a good scaffold is that it launders a bad answer into a trustworthy-looking one. The mitigation isn't more scaffolding. It's the human in the loop who actually understands the domain, whose job the scaffold protects rather than replaces. Build all four threads, and then make absolutely sure a competent human still reads the result and can veto it. The scaffold earns the human more time to think. It does not earn the right to skip the human.
Erinome: Iapetus, the governance sharpening.
Iapetus: The sharpening is that governance is not a feature you turn on, it's a discipline you run. The workbench gives you an architecture that can be compliant. It does not give you compliance. Compliance is prompt hygiene enforced every time, small-cell suppression enforced every time, execution kept on controlled infrastructure verified every time, and an audit trail someone actually reviews. The moment those become "usually" instead of "always," the architecture is doing nothing for you. So my one edge: write the three-layer discipline into your standard operating procedure, and make the tool refuse to proceed when a layer is skipped, rather than trusting the user to remember. Governance that depends on memory fails.
Erinome: Kore, the record sharpening.
Kore: Make the record the artefact you ship, not a thing you could reconstruct on request. There's a huge practical difference between "the provenance exists somewhere in the logs" and "the provenance is the deliverable, and the analysis rides along inside it." If the record is the primary object, then every incentive points toward keeping it complete, because it's what you hand over. If it's a secondary log, it rots. So the concrete step is: define your deliverable as the bundle, goal plus code plus environment plus results plus critic-flags plus resolutions, and treat a bare number without that bundle as incomplete work. That single framing choice does more for reproducibility than any amount of clever tooling.
Erinome: Achernar, and Rasalgethi, the closing edges from each of you.
Achernar: Mine is short. Every one of these threads is a way to earn trust more efficiently. None of them is a substitute for the judgment that decides whether the answer is actually right about the world. The scaffold moves faster; it does not know more. Keep the person who knows more in the room.
Rasalgethi: And mine is the optimistic counterweight to that, because both are true at once. The reason this matters is that the scaffold takes the tedious ninety percent, the plumbing, the boilerplate, the assumption-checking you were too rushed to do, and clears it out of the way, so the human's scarce judgment gets spent on the ten percent that actually needs it. That's not automating the scientist away. That's aiming the scientist at the part only they can do. Used like that, the four threads together don't replace expertise. They concentrate it. That's the version of this worth building toward.
Erinome: That's the note to end on, and it's the honest one: a scaffold that concentrates human judgment rather than replacing it, built on four interlocking pieces, generation you can check, records you can read, data you can keep home, and compute you can control. Each is useful alone. Together they describe a way of working with sensitive research and clinical data that is faster without being reckless, provided the discipline holds and the competent human stays in the loop. If you build any part of this, build the critic with a real checklist, keep the data local, suppress the small cells, insist on portable code, and make the record the thing you deliver. That's the whole of it. Thanks to Rasalgethi, Kore, Achernar, Iapetus, and Charon. This has been State of Play. I'm Erinome.